[Applause]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number isn't it 126.
no no it's 125 yeah so i somehow
imagined that the last
the last live stream was a multiple of
five uh something something has gone
wrong no here we are perfectly
um
i want to say cubic a perfect cube a
perfect we are that square
yeah according to something
um so i do want to say uh
the uh helicopter sound effect is new
we're still dialing it in but
yeah i did want to say uh we apologize
to our regular live viewers for coming
to you at an odd hour we know that that
is not ideal
uh in this case it was unavoidable
when we travel when we interact with
people we are increasingly hearing that
uh the dark horse podcast is keeping
people sane and we feel an intense
obligation to to people who feel that
way so that's why we're slotting this in
here
in the middle of the week but that's
actually not the only population is
another population that quite apart from
being kept sane is being driven crazy by
the dark horse podcast we also feel an
obligation to those people and so here
we are
playing our role in the universe
indeed
yeah so as i've mentioned the last few
uh few episodes we have a very strange
schedule coming up so
today we're going to be talking to you
about the new current thing
who's to say what that is and it made
change in the next five minutes but
we're going to be talking to you about
the new current thing today um but first
some logistics uh no q a today basically
when we're coming to you in the middle
of the week uh we are not going to be
doing q a we will come to you again this
saturday though in three short days at
our normal time 12 30 noon
12 30 noon 30 pacific on saturday may
7th and we'll have a q a after that um
and then it's going to be uh two and a
half weeks before we come back to you
again you've got a lot of travel that
we've just been doing and it's coming up
on thursday may 26th and then saturday
may 28th and then a few saturdays uh
thereafter so um we are trying to get a
few of these episodes in because as
brett said we are um we are so
grateful for our audience and
uh for the impact that we understand
um ourselves to be making
so um we encourage you as always
someone has stolen my prop
has stolen my copy of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century brett
why do you think it was me you're the
only other person who sits here it
doesn't matter uh we encourage you to
read uh this
this book um which
provides an evolutionary toolkit to
uh to modernity and in fact to grappling
with the new current thing almost no
matter what it is
uh it's been coveted for a while it was
ukraine for a while and we'll be talking
today about what it is now
i just think we need to get our
terminology in order it is useful for
grappling with the current current thing
right that way one and done the current
current thing whatever it happens to be
this book will help i hope so i think so
i hope so yes
uh we are live streaming uh right now on
youtube and odyssey and the video will
also be available on spotify and then of
course the audio anywhere you find your
podcasts apple etc um
in natural selections my sub stack this
week i
posted on uh the idea that seems to be
common in many circles now that if you
don't agree with me it must be because
you're ignorant and we're going to be
sharing a little bit about that today
including the the naming of the
phenomenon by dr elana redstone who i
was privileged to re-meet this week
and
i guess the only other logistics are to
once again
um thank our audience we are supported
by our audience we appreciate you
subscribing and liking and sharing both
the full videos you can find here
wherever you're watching um and um and
also at darkhorse podcast clips which
are the uh the
stations that's not right what are they
called channels
channels uh on both odyssey and youtube
and the clips are uh very shareable and
they make great gifts
not really um but
i thought i'd try it out i don't know
but they're but but they're imminently
shareable and and um
yeah just just that and of course we
appreciate financial support from those
who can afford it most weeks you can ask
questions on our q a not today though we
won't be doing a q a you can join one of
our patreons where we have
monthly private q and a's and brett has
conversations
with people and of course we have
sponsors which we started doing a little
more than a year ago
and uh we are grateful to them all of
the sponsors that we read ads for are
for products or services that we
actually and truly vouch for
so as usual we have three right at the
top of the hour and then no more during
the show here we go
our first sponsor this week is vevo
barefoot which long time viewers and
listeners will be well familiar with
vivo barefoot makes shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by vivos are made by people
who know feet these shoes are a
revelation
we love them they are beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they're fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot
but modern shoes that are overly
cushioned and strangely shaped have
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a health crisis one
in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them the number of people
wearing vevo barefoots is growing once
people start wearing these shoes they
don't seem to stop
vivo barefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
to everyday wear they are certified b
corp pioneering regenerative business
principles and their footwear is
producing use is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild in it
go to vivobarefoot.com
darkhorse to get an exclusive offer of
20 off
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse
our second sponsor this week is md
hearing aid
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone can afford
recognizing that about 95 of the people
who need a hearing aid only require a
few settings he removed some of the less
often needed components and he cut out
the middleman and now md hearing aid
makes a rechargeable hearing aid that is
fda registered and costs a small
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus is water
resistant and up to three feet of water
and you don't need a prescription you
buy it directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product since it doesn't
make sense for us to do so and this is
what she said
quote with my particular type of hearing
loss a deep male voice in a noisy room
is the hardest situation for me to hear
and understand speech
i wore the md hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced man in a
room with a lot of white noise the md
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars i was amazed at
how effective they are end quote
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over six hundred thousand
satisfied customers they offer a 45 day
risk free trial with 100 money back
guarantee
get clinic level care for 80 less with
md hearing aid
go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo core dark
horse to get their buy one get one deal
a pair of hearing aids cost just 299.99
plus they're adding a free extra
charging case a 100 value just for
listeners of dark horse so head to
mdhearingaid.com
use our promo code darkhorse or you can
even call them at 1-833-772-1392
our final sponsor this week is one we
are very excited about it's a new
sponsor and i must say i don't do uh
giddy but i really couldn't be more
thrilled to have uh to have this one as
a sponsor it is ralston college ralston
college is a new institution of higher
education i think of it as the
just-in-time university it is located in
savannah georgia it is both a revival
and a reinvention of the university an
intellectual home for all those who seek
truth with courage it offers online
courses podcasts and live lectures
this year ralston college is launching
its first in-person degree program a
masters in the humanities the program
features a multi-disciplinary curriculum
of philosophy literature art music and
architecture
focused on the history and concept of
the human self it starts with a term of
language study in greece for those of
you who are interested in doing some
greco-roman this is perfect for you it's
really not greco-roman no it's a decent
pun
students will live and study on the
island of samos and will travel to key
sites of the hellenic world such as the
parthenon and delphi
the year will continue in savannah
georgia on a campus in the historic
center all successful applicants will
receive full scholarships extraordinary
students who seek to do the hard
thinking our time demands are encouraged
to apply the deadline for applications
is may 21st visit
ralston.edu
darkhorse that's
r-a-l-s-t-o-n dot ac slash dark horse
for more information about this once in
a lifetime opportunity
and i will say
just end the ad read and let us riff a
tiny bit about that sure let's do that
yeah this is now us just talking on our
own
um let's just say we have had a
conversation uh with the head of ralston
and um we are very excited for multiple
reasons one we all know that something
has to address the vacuum left by the
collapse of the academy and you know
frankly anything that succeeds at the
job is welcome
but it is also the case that ralston
seems when i first heard about it i was
a little dubious because it was very
online but it turns out the plan is very
much to have a physical campus which
will
create an environment where the kind of
teaching that you and i uh got so
familiar with and used to such good
effect at evergreen can happen which is
uh marvelous
but it also seems distinctly aware that
removing the woke from the university
system is
necessary but not sufficient to build a
system that works and so in any case
this is an experiment that i think
should very much be on everyone's radar
and uh is a very hopeful sign at a
moment when when there are not so many
hopeful signs indeed so i will say um
that i was i was in austin this weekend
at a university of austin event at the
uh
the first first principle summit i think
it's going to be the first first
principle summit anyway the first the
first summit and there are a lot of
really extraordinary people there and
one of the things i said uh to
informally to the group as we were just
being introduced to one another the
night before the full day of um sort of
getting down to business was that um i'm
hopeful the university of austin can be
such an institution
and i did not someone else actually did
mention ralston by name um but what what
i what i said without mentioning any
other institutions by name and there's
actually a third initiative that we're
aware of that we aren't going to be
talking about publicly yet
we should all want all of these
initiatives to survive and to be
extraordinary to push each other to be
their best selves and you know maybe
more importantly yet to therefore push
any existing institutions that can still
save themselves they can still pull
themselves out of their death spiral
to wake up and
fix themselves and go far far beyond as
you said far far beyond not being woke
anymore
but to actually
recovering the goals of of higher ed to
you know to both honor and respect
orthodoxy and to leave space well open
for heterodoxy and to not confuse the
new orthodoxy uh with something that is
still heterodox and preserve that at the
cost of all else and to not deny reality
and to not pretend that we um aren't
living shared lives in which we are
dependent on one another
um i will also add another
important sign in that direction is that
ralston is not going to have a vaccine
requirement as i understand it for
incoming students and what that means
from our perspective is
that uh
as far as we know all defensible
positions are welcome at ralston and
shouldn't that be a founding principle
of every university
so anyway it's a
uh it's a great thing and we are
we're very glad to have them uh as
sponsors and we are very pleased to be
in conversation with them uh we we hope
and expect good things will come from
this indeed and just um you know the ad
read is long since over but just to
remind um people the reason that this is
coming up right now uh is that
may 21st is ralston's deadline for
applications for their first in-person
degree program which is an m.a in the
humanities which will begin with the
term in greece doing language study and
and other study and you do not have to
like the pun about doing some
greco-roman that's actually not required
yeah people
reasonable people can differ over the
quality of that pun
excellent
excellent
okay
um so here we are
um here we are midday on a beautiful
spring day in the pacific northwest um
but of course and and our epic tabby
fairfax for those of you just listening
has shown up is interested in the birds
uh is thinking about spring as uh as all
of us in the northern hemisphere um
ought to be free to do and yet we are we
are constantly compelled now to think
only about the new current thing
what what is it that is that has grabbed
us and dragged us this week
into a frenzy of anger and
retaliatory social media posts and
frustration and depression sometimes and
anxiety and you know
all of the things
uh that keep us at fever pitch far from
our best selves far from being the most
productive
creative
caring loving
uh
compassionate people that we can be so
um
i thought briefly this moment
that the new current thing uh so the new
current thing as you have said before uh
here was i believe marc andreessen's
framing
a couple couple
couple many weeks ago now basically when
um
when
putin when russia invaded ukraine and
suddenly no one's talking about covet
and everyone's talking about ukraine and
everyone's replaced needles with
uh ukrainian flags as in their twitter
avatars etc uh andreessen said something
to the effect of
the the new current thing is what we're
allowed to talk about
we are allowed to be uh nuanced about
the so somehow he pointed out that we
were allowed to be nuanced about the
last current thing but you're not
allowed with the current current thing
right and you know and um you know it's
not
the nuances the being allowed to have
nuance is going to take time right so
you know we're not really allowed to
have
nuance about covid yet oh no you and i
never will be that that was my extension
of this principle that we will never be
vindicated no matter how right we were
yeah because that's not how it works you
can't very well vindicate people who
were trying to be nuanced in real time
otherwise you validate the concept of
being known but if you were certain
before you're now allowed to quietly
change your opinion without ever
acknowledging it in any way and um and
and move forward right and in fact the
powers that be that presumably whether
they orchestrate these things or not
love the current thing right because it
keeps us so divided when otherwise we
might recognize what's going on those
people they actually really like the
folks who rush in you know a day late
and a dollar short with the nuance
because the point is that is who we then
will herald as having been correct in
order not to vindicate the process of
being nuanced in real time that can be
pointed to as if that is the success of
democracy and discourse and and all such
yep
uh so the new current thing could have
been the release of um boy i've seen it
variously reported but many tens of
thousands of pages of documents from
pfizer this week that's up that's a lot
of documents
go on which was on the calendar the date
when it was going to be released was no
surprise to anyone um we
have not gone through the many tens of
thousands of pages in the pfizer
documents
um and in fact uh you know
we've both looked at it a little bit a
little bit
uh search in any browser of your choice
you know be it be it you know go go
big brother and go chrome or go brave or
go you know anywhere in between go brave
or go home that's my feeling go pray for
cochrane no
terrible i know but the front opinion so
um so search on in any browser on you
know fiser data release or fiser
documents you know don't put in
the words like data dump don't put don't
put in the words that clearly have the
connotation of the people who ex you
know who already have an opinion about
this
put in as mutual search terms as you can
at least as of mid to late morning
pacific time today on may
4th
uh 2022
nobody in the mainstream media is saying
word one about this
massive this is the second of what's to
be many um
court mandated release of documents
um and
and it was as you said on the calendar
and no one's saying anything about it
and given that the mainstream media
isn't saying anything about it um it
can't possibly be the new current thing
right it's not allowed to be visor is
not the new current thing right i want
to point out about this mandate pfizer
wanted to wait 75 years before
delivering these documents the court
forced them to do it on a rapid schedule
and there are bombshells in all of it
and i don't know what all is in this one
it's going to take time for people to
carefully sort it out but there are
certainly indicators in there about what
pfizer knew and didn't know about the
effect of its vaccines on
pregnant women on
breastfeeding women
and on the disease itself that is
supposedly vaccinating and cancer on the
disease the efficacy is the correct term
uh of its vaccine relative to
um the
outcomes the contracting covid um
and um what was the last thing that was
uh oh
no
i don't remember but um but anyway there
are a number of interesting things in
there that are that are definitely going
to unfold over time but of course we
probably won't hear very much about them
because the new current thing is so
irresistible
yes
uh the leak from the supreme court
uh and the future of roe versus wade is
the new current thing of course
so that is what we are going to spend
some time talking about today
yes now i do think uh you know
we have to pressure test andreessen's
point about the current thing right i do
think one challenge to it is that we
have had
something like
four current things in the last few
months in rapid succession
um and
maybe that is part of the model maybe
that this this you know to me
one always has to to wonder whether or
not the events that we see are fully
organic which is unlikely fully
synthetic which is unlikely or some
mixture of the two and so which of these
things are orchestrated to capture our
attention and keep us nicely divided so
we don't recognize our common interests
which of these things are just the
unfolding of history in the way that it
will we don't know but it's augmented
and exacerbated by the speed of
communication that is uh not just
possible but almost required by social
media right and so you know we've had uh
everything downstream of covid was you
know was the current thing for a very
long time we've had ukraine we've had
elon musk twitter and free speech we've
had leah thomas we've had
winning women's swimming
right um so we've had these like winning
for those just listening was brief scare
quotes
we've had these brief current things
which may or may not
we will have to ask mark um
what he intended and which of these
things he thinks counts or whether they
all fit because they simply do the the
job of um keeping us at each other's
throats but nonetheless it is certainly
worth everything we're going to talk
extensively today about the current
thing because what choice do we have
no i i guess i and i think i framed it
kind of that way too and i wanted to to
walk that back a little bit we have a
lot of choice
and in fact in general um it is not in
our interest or your entrance interest
our audience or anyone's interest to
feel compelled to think on and listen to
thoughts on the new current thing
because we are being told that that is
what one must think on is precisely the
opposite but in this case
there is
sufficient overlap both with our
expertise and uh many of the other
cultural things going on at the moment
that we are going to do so you know
whereas by comparison for instance uh we
said very little about ukraine
uh this is this is true um and i also do
not mean to imply that we actually have
no choice but to talk about whatever is
being delivered but in your case in my
case there's actually every reason that
i think we need to talk about this one
that there is in fact a lot of content
relative to what it means that roe v
wade is likely to be overturned here
that is explicitly biological and
evolutionary and frankly trying to do
this without those pieces of uh tool kit
available is uh a incredibly dangerous
and b a fool's errand right these things
are highly relevant so i think in your
case in my case we don't really have a
choice but i was being facetious about
of course we must talk about whatever
they want us talking about but in so
doing
let us keep track of the two things
separately right and maybe it's even
three things there's a
hey
the current thing has just been
delivered
utterly predictable that it would
captivate everyone right it has been
delivered by some force that wants us
talking about it whether that is one
rogue individual who felt that this
needed to be delivered into the world or
something larger than one rogue
individual who had a purpose in making
the conversation divert to this we don't
know
but nonetheless somebody wanted us
talking about this and we need to track
what it is that that somebody hoped to
accomplish it may be narrow it may have
to do with roe v wade it may be that
they were trying to change what the
court was going to do um and that public
pressure was to be exerted but
nonetheless that is an
important uh
an important question
the second thing that is important is
the fact of the leak itself which is not
absolutely unprecedented but is close to
it and so what kind of change does that
imply about the rules of play in our
system as it were
some of us think it's very dire actually
others are like well okay so we learned
about this a few weeks early what's the
big deal i'm definitely over in the this
is a very serious
change in the way things are done it
compromises the court even more
compromised than it's already become
and that's that's danger it increases
the danger to us
maybe we need to just say in a couple of
sentences what has happened because some
people may some people may not actually
know and you're smirking but we also we
also hope that people will listen to
this not right now right and um it is it
is an error always of communication and
specifically of anything that attempts
to be educational to assume that your
audience already knows what you're
talking about and to just launch in to
the analysis without describing what the
thing is
so um in february i believe
um there was a case heard by the supreme
court of the united states
and there was a majority opinion drafted
then with justice alito as the lead
author uh with four other justices
signing on making it a five to four
decision the four other justices being
clarence thomas
and then um and i i am not casting
aspersions here but just for sort of um
categorization purposes the three
appointees um from the trump
administration we have gorsuch kavanaugh
and coney barrett um signing on to the
majority opinion that in its draft form
was leaked um uh written by alito uh
leaked this week like two days ago i
guess uh and um it makes it clear that
the court is arguing that roe v weighed
the landmark
uh decision handed down by scotus by the
supreme court of the united states in
1973
which provided federal protections for
american women to get abortions
before the fetus is viable
uh will be overturned
so that is uh that is a nutshell i hope
i didn't make any errors there i didn't
hear any um so the document emerged in
politico
people have argued that politico is
guilty of something for publishing it
this is nonsense that they were behaving
in a journalistically responsible
journalists can do what they do with
what they get right whether or not they
should have they should have been given
the document by anybody the fact that
they have the document makes it
legitimate for them to report on this is
a well-established principle and so they
did that right
but
in any case it emerged and so what we
have is kind of a snapshot of the
majority opinion back on i think
february 10th
right that's quite a while ago in uh you
know
current thing time
so it is impossible that the
and i should say it's a night i have it
open here i've not read all of it but
i've i've i've read some of it it's a 98
page opinion as you would expect you
know this is not a two-page brief this
is a this is a substantive document a
substantive document and um most of the
people who have intense opinions about
it won't have
won't have read
and i think that's a terrible mistake
because at least even just understanding
what reasoning the court is deploying
the majority is deploying in uh
presumably you know we don't know that
the court
in may of 2022 is in the same place that
it was in early february it is not
uncommon i think i'm not a legal scholar
i'm a biologist but it is not uncommon
for the back and forth over these things
to cause some wobble and this is part of
the reason
that the
veil behind which the court functions is
so important is that the court is
actually a deliberative body
and that deliberative body
if it is you know just as twitter is not
an ideal place to discuss you know
religion right um the court
if it has to do so in public is not
going to be in a position
to you know to explore arguments as
fully as they need to in order to serve
the public's interest so anyway that
veil was breached somebody released this
which could mean
uh you know almost anything it could be
a justice it could be a clerk uh it
could be
that
some
state-level actor
tuned into communications and hijacked
the thing and thought that creating
chaos at the moment would be a good idea
we don't know so before i say a little
bit about um
just my position on abortion
generally
um you were framing a couple of things
that you thought we need to keep track
of and i'm not sure they're actually
things that i feel compelled to keep
track of but so far they were about um
who might have leaked it and
and that was the second one there's
the purpose of the leak whether there is
something else that we are not paying
attention to that we probably should at
this moment that's an important question
there's the fact of the leak doesn't
matter what you think of the content
doesn't matter what you think of the
subject
right the fact of a leak is an important
change in the way things function it is
you know it's like the foul becoming a
an acceptable move the intentional foul
becoming an acceptable move in
basketball right it changes the game
um and then there's the question of the
content itself which has to be divided
into two right there's the question of
should abortion be a federally protected
right and then there's a question of is
row the proper way to do that and these
two things there are lots of people
myself included who believe that there
should be a federal protection but
believe that actually roe is a terrible
way to do this and that
history has been shaped by the
feebleness of that mechanism so i will
say um that
i am i'm even farther from a legal
scholar than you are because i don't
have any lawyers in my natal family
whereas you do
don't rub it in
it wasn't meant as a dispersion but
perhaps you could take it as one
um but i have talked to
smart
and you know beyond smart beyond capable
lawyers on both sides of this
ideological divide
who have argued people
lawyers who understand law well on both
sides of this they do think that
abortion should be a federally protected
right or they do not believe it who say
regardless of whether you think
that the u.s should end up with abortion
having a federally protected right
that roe should not stand that it itself
is not is not good law and in fact um
very quickly in the alito document um
the the leaked document he starts and
you know this is this is where i was
skimming a lot because he starts to make
on behalf of the five um
justices who are signing on to this that
argument precisely that this this was
based in you know it it it borrows from
um
precedent and too many amendments it
seems inconsistent uh and i'm sort of
going to drop it there with regard to
any legal analysis because it's not my
not my wheelhouse well let's come back
to that because i think it is important
but i will say um i believe even ruth
bader ginsburg believed that roe was bad
law right and she i believe equally
clearly was a strong advocate for a
federal protection for abortion rights
but the the problem is that
unfortunately the way our system works
if it is to work at all it has to work
on the basis of the court interpreting
the constitution and it has to interpret
it based on you know a legal theory is
it doing so in the modern context as a
sort of pragmatic
updating mechanism that can evaluate
modern reality and impose it on a static
document and say here's what the law
should say some people believe this sort
of thing others think that the only
thing that matters is original intent
right original intent could be a matter
of the founders themselves it could be a
matter of the thought at the time that
the founders or the writers of the
amendments um generated their their uh
their work but nonetheless the problem
is
that as with science right
the system has to work otherwise the
product isn't any good right so you
can't say that because i believe that a
woman's right to choose an abortion is
at least sometimes
so obvious that it should have a federal
protection the question is was the
reasoning that the court used
sufficiently robust to actually sustain
it or does it require us to keep bailing
the boat as the water is flooding in and
i would say
you know at the very least we should
recognize that
you know
every election that i remember every
presidential election has been held
hostage to this question right it haunts
every presidential election it's not its
only effect it has many others but at
the very least
that problem is one that has a
significant force in history it prevents
us from escaping the duopoly for one
thing because the point of the argument
is how dare you suggest anything other
than the duopoly because rho is in
jeopardy right that's always the
argument right now maybe that changes
downstream of this decision it's used as
a bludgeon you can vote your conscience
next time this time you have to vote x
because we are defending the thing that
we have made sure you have to continue
to care about because it is under threat
um interesting though that you bring up
uh
that you compare this to science because
i think one of
science and the law are very very
different
right science is inherently that the
scientific process is about trying to
discover what is true
and
the law you know legal cases would like
to discover what is true but that is not
as i understand it the actual like
ultimate
uh
goal right it's it's about um are we in
agreement i mean i'm sort of waiting for
you to jump in here with like the right
language for like what is what is the
law what is the law ultimately trying to
do and then
i'm sorry i have to interrupt you in
mansplain because you've asked me to do
it so nicely but then i but i do
but i do want to respond to what you
were saying before first of all i only
mean something very narrow which is the
relationship between the process and the
product is the same as the relationship
in science i don't mean that you're not
answering the question i so don't don't
go there i just like if science is about
um discovering what is true what is law
about okay
um the court is about two things and by
the court i mean all of them they're
about two things they're about findings
of fact and findings of law so the
findings of fact thing is really
loosely analogous to the scientific
process what actually happened and then
the question is well okay we agree that
x person shot why person
what we're you know both sides could
agree to that and then the question what
are the implications right was the
person acting in self-defense or was the
person is the person guilty of homicide
right so that is a finding of law okay
good so
uh in science
long-held beliefs um
do tend to continue to be held because
there is precedent although we don't
tend to use that kind of language in
science
but because what we have believed for a
while tends to be the easiest thing to
continue to believe it is hard to
dislodge long-held but wrong beliefs but
it is understood by everyone who is
doing science that that is
a necessary thing to seek even if you
personally find it very hard to for
whatever your perverse incentives might
be whereas in the law
there is um an explicit and explicit
category i'm i'm sure i'm using the
wrong word but starry decisis
um the latin terms a principle starry
decisis which you invoked by alito in um
in this
uh
opinion
uh which basically says if it has
already been established um by the same
body in this case by the supreme court
uh then you should let it stand
and um that is you know
de facto we all tend to do this like the
things that we we have already agreed on
even if we're kind of coming to realize
oh man maybe not um we kind of continue
to to do it and
um
it is explicitly part of
the law and explicitly not part of
science
okay now this gets all tangled up here
first of all starry decisis is
interesting that starry decisis um
is effectively uh
latin for chesterton's fence at some
level right basically um i'm kidding of
course but
what it means is that if other people in
our positions earlier came to this
decision don't mess if the court has
settled the law then the court needs to
think really hard about the wisdom of
unsettling but that is not a it's not a
an absolute in fact the court unsettles
itself all the time and in many cases we
regard this as very important now of
course i should point out yet again and
maybe i'll do it three or four more
times i'm a biologist i'm not a legal
scholar so if i get something wrong yeah
hey alert me i'm i'm open to it but um
take for example the
uh i get this right it's the plessy
versus ferguson decision in which
separate but equal was
upheld
bad law yeah by the court and then this
was reversed with good law in brown
versus board of education right so this
is a case i think that's right in which
um you know the court does what the
court does which is it overcomes the
burden hey let's leave well enough alone
uh with respect to cases that are
already adjudicated just because the
current court might have adjudicated it
differently doesn't justify us opening
it up on the other hand when the court
screws up a future court has to fix it
right and so that's kind of the question
that we are faced with and of course
courts will screw up but you know i
think story decisis
operates effect as you say as
chesterton's fence as breaks
on the politicization of judges and you
know judges are supposed to be of course
outside of the executive and legislative
branches but they're still human beings
just like individual scientists or human
beings with biases and that's why we
have um you know that's why we have
statistics when they're well done and
replication when it's well done and um
you know in experimental design when
it's well done all of which are um you
know baffles against the bias of the
individuals doing the work
similarly
you have you know nine judges not one on
the supreme court of the united states
and you have principles like starry
decisis which say ah you know not so
fast
hold on you have to have a really high
bar basically before you before you go
back and tinker with decisions that have
already been arrived at and imagine that
you didn't have this right imagine that
every time an administration
came in and appointed a judge and it
you know changes potentially every
decision of every past court they want
it all relitigated and the court has no
bias in favor of leaving well enough
alone you know i'm just in my mind i'm
watching you know a fixed a a volume a
fixed volume in which the heat just
keeps going up and it's just going to
explode right there's no united states
the walls are beginning to bulge
oh they're bulging but the point is a
system that doesn't have a bias quite
fixed at this point
right oh yeah and you know
and this is part of this is part of why
the leak itself is so important is
listen
these are just people right we treat
them as sort of you know in fact uh
these the supreme court justices right
my brother points out that they dress as
a kind of religious order that they are
set apart by this bizarre garb and the
circumstance surrounding the court it's
like an oracle at delphi and it's
obviously absurd in the context of the
fact that these are just people right on
the other hand it kind of needs to be
that in our minds in order for it to do
the job that it has to do and even when
it does stuff that we hate you know um
uh it doesn't we have to respect that
the process is actually keeping us alive
even if the process does things that we
disagree with and may even be
you know border unobjectively wrong
um and so to open up hey i know we could
start pressuring the court by leaking
stuff about their internal deliberations
well suddenly now everybody on the court
is worried
you know about how the intermediate
steps will look and then there they are
it is going to look like twitter and so
it's very the leak itself is very
serious and um
uh if you don't see why
you need to go back and rethink it
because you really do want a court that
has the insulation to make good
decisions because sometimes those
decisions could potentially be you know
life or death for the republic yeah
okay can we pivot a little bit um
yes although we should probably touch on
the question of
why it's bad law and what might have
been better
okay okay we are going to spend the
whole rest of the time talking about all
this oh okay then it will come up in
line that's fine
you can go for it
um
okay well let's just put it on the table
then so i think what the court did was
that effectively there's a decision i
think it's griswold
in which the court
rolled its eyes at i believe a
connecticut law that tried to bar the
use of birth control
even by married people
and the court basically said
come on you really want the state
you know like i think peeping tom was
actually the uh
the metaphor is functioning like a
peeping tom in the bedrooms of married
people who want to make one decision or
another about the use of birth control
this is so this is
in fact what they said was that it was
effectively treading on
an informally established principle in a
way that was egregious and so what's the
informally so i don't i don't know this
basically people were entitled to make a
certain amount of
to do between couples that privacy of
the bedroom allowed people to do a
certain amount of decision making that
was outside of the purview of government
to say anything about oh okay but um
as i understand it the right to privacy
is not guaranteed right the we the the
constitution does not actually provide
as much as as much as
i i i would like that to be in the
constitution it is no it's there in the
fourth amendment and the problem is i
think and again i'm a biologist i'm not
a legal scholar so i'm working off the
topic
but
the well
it is inferred from the fourth amendment
but hold on the the place where roe is
uh built is the 14th amendment which
invokes
um privacy as a subordinate of liberty
which is in the 14th amendment and so
this is where you get into hey how
robust is this law anyway to protect
abortion as a matter of privacy is
dubious whereas it could have been
protected again in the 14th amendment by
the equal protection clause right and so
i think this is this was ruth bader
ginsburg's position
is that the 14th amendment
has a clause which guarantees equal
protection under the law and equal
protection under the law is
challenged by the notion that you could
cross the border from this is going to
be an implausible example but from
california to nevada
and you know on one side of that border
a woman might be fully entitled to have
an abortion and on the other side of
that border a woman in the identical
circumstance might be guilty of murder
and the question is is that a violation
of the right to equal protection under
the law for these two women i think that
is the more robust logic that many
people would have preferred
that seems to go right into the
extraordinarily large rabbit warren that
is uh states rights arguments
exactly exactly which is another reason
that this is so contentious is that
states rights is
simultaneously an important principle
for real and also a mechanism for
dodging good law right it is a it is a
kind of sabotage and that tension can't
won't disappear that tension cannot be
disappeared that is a trade-off that is
inherent in having a united states of
america exactly this is it is an
inherent tension and i would point out
that that's not entirely a bad thing
that one of the things that
trade-offs happen well not only
and tension is valuable it's not i i
will go one step further a dynamic
system as complex as a nation in order
to work is going to work through
principles of tension between competing
values right it is exactly the way not
just valuable but necessary it is the
way a biological organism functions for
a reason right yeah but you i know but
not all of our listeners will know that
you are not equating an organism with a
society there are ways in which society
may act as an evolved organism but it is
not the same no but it is the same in
one way which i believe you know we'll
find out if i've overlooked something
here but my basic point as an
evolutionary theorist and this i am
qualified to speak on professionally
is that what you have are two complex
not complicated complex dynamic systems
in need of regulation
and the point is a body to function is
regulated right a society to function is
regulated and the question is how will
you regulate it you will do so through
tensions between competing things and
everything in the body is done this way
everything from you know picking up a
pen because you have two opposing
muscles that can you know can uh
adjust the position of your arm to your
temperature
the whole thing right dynamic tension so
the fact that there is
this dynamic tension between
uh
competing desires on the part of
disparate or not so disparate parts of
the body where both everything fails if
one of them wins and thus drives the
other extinct
those competing desires may cry foul
wait i didn't get what i wanted right
then sorry it's about the body and the
body politic is not an evolved organism
the same way a body is but there is an
analogy yeah so anyway those tensions i
think are good the states rights versus
federal one is uh is an important it's
an uncomfortable one i mean you know on
what issue do we not find ourselves
gnashing our our teeth on one side or
the other of this thing but yeah and
actually this um this is a good segue to
to kind of where i wanted to go that you
know it seems to me that if if roe is
reversed
um
if roe is reversed an american woman
in need of an abortion may be able to
get one only in states that um yes have
legal abortion but also engage in a
affirmative care again with the air
quotes scare quotes affirmative care for
children who declare themselves to be
the opposite sex but
notice not
having affirmative care for children to
declare themselves to be tractors or
umbrellas
rainbows um so affirmative care only for
the sex confu briefly sex confused
children
will be available in the same states
where abortions are available and it may
also be those states where parents don't
have parental rights if their children
decide to start transitioning socially
at school for instance
um and if the parents resist um
this
batshit nuttery
then they are
potentially in themselves in breach of
law
all three of those things
you know one of which the first abortion
rights um with limits i am absolutely in
favor of um somehow go together now some
somehow and then and then we will have
states where none of those things are
likely to be possible and um you know i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to rank these
things in terms of their importance
and
um and yet i find it to be a
particularly egregious and insane moment
um that we find ourselves potentially in
in that situation choosing between
states that have um
in which in which those are the options
so um i want to uh correct one thing
that you said because was it about
batshit nuttery no no not at all i
thought that was something i think i'm
going to keep that yeah yeah
more power to you but um
the
you said
abortion rights which you are absolutely
in favor of and i know what you mean
right you are i said with limits
did you yes my brain
hung up at absolute because i know i
think what you mean i'm absolutely in
favor of with limits okay good well then
maybe maybe i don't need to
yeah the helicopter uh sound is actually
it's very realistic but
so
um
row was passed in 1973.
uh we were we were but toddlers
um actually i don't know it's four
toddlers something like that i was still
toddling at the time
um
and we might ask though um how the year
2022 is not like the year 1973.
you know we
we grew up i actually i don't know you
know and not being a girl as you never
were um i don't know the degree to which
not yet nope never never nope
um
this may not have been something that
your mother ever talked to you about but
my mother
who was you know
lucky and made choices such that she was
never in a position to have to try to
get
an illegal abortion
but told me stories um from her own
childhood that she heard about with
regard to
um the other kinds of you know back
alley and coat hangers and you know
these these terms that that everyone who
has thought about pre-row
um and who is pro-choice has in their
head is this sort of you know this this
this boogie man of like this this could
be where we go to again
uh and um i certainly you know i like i
said i am absolutely in favor of um
abortion with limits legal abortion with
limits
um
but
it is different now it is so it's
different there are more
options
there are there are um chemical options
abortification for terminating
unwanted pregnancies that didn't exist
before
uh and there are more ways to both
spread funds and communicate people
between people such that uh a kind of um
you know an underground situation that
wasn't even all that underground seems
much more plausible
uh you clearly want to
jump in here i think uh
those two
plan b or its equivalent
and
the different environment that would
allow people to have good information
but there's also just simply the
different um
a much relaxed social environment in
which the stigma
is
uh greatly reduced and so the stigma of
what the stigma of having become
pregnant
under
unmarried circumstances for example
there's effectively
there's very little so that's going to
run well
presumably in some cultures and some
subcultures and demographics there's
still um
but i feel like that runs in the
opposite direction to the other two that
the relaxed stigma means that there may
be more
unwanted pregnancies
that are that
that people might
end up wanting to terminate whereas the
other two
um you know the other two changes uh
mean that even if roe gets overturned
and is not quickly replaced with
something else that um
that guarantees the right to abortion
across all 50 states
that
young women will have access
well uh so my
i agree that that reduced stigma
increases the chances of such
pregnancies yes but
my point was
we've got a couple things in play at
once right there is the importance of
the legal protection
and then there's the question of how
many actual pregnancies does it change
the outcome of
and
the reduced stigma
i believe means that the number is lower
because
people
you know the number of people who cannot
drive to a across a state line where
abortion is again going to be protected
is going to be relatively small and the
barriers to doing it are non-existent um
i think
i think that is likely to be true for
middle-class people and higher i do not
think that that is any more true now
than it was before
for poor people
and
and in fact
the possibly decreased stigma against
getting pregnant outside of wedlock for
instance uh may mean that there is a
greater need and um
and that the overturning of rho uh means
that there is reduced reduced access and
we know and we know there will be at
some level immediately reduced access
right so um
there's a lot to say here but um
how about this let me let me go here
next and i still haven't actually no let
me i'm going to skip forward uh i wrote
about abortion in 2018 and i want to
just share the first three paragraphs of
that piece and i'll and i'll link to it
and um
this was when justice kennedy had just
announced retirement and before
kavanaugh had um uh had gotten ascended
to the bench i didn't know if ascended
was the right word i was trying to avoid
the word ascended i think it is
physically elevated so we can just
send it okay
um
and of course at that point um
there was a lot of discussion about
what um
what that might mean for row uh and so
you can show my screen if you like zack
like i say i will also post this is
oh yeah i know it's plugged in
just go ahead and read so it was this
was published in
uh on august 24th 2018 in ariel
and
here are the first three paragraphs
nobody wants an abortion no woman wants
one and no man who has thought about the
issue wants any woman he cares about to
be in a position in which she feels
compelled to have one
sometimes though in the service of the
greater good abortions are necessary
in the wake of the announcement of
american supreme court justice kennedy's
imminent retirement the issue of
abortion once again became central in
many news feeds it is a topic
perennially guaranteed to provoke
outrage all the more politically useful
now that former hot-button topics like
gay marriage and the legalization of
marijuana have slid out of the
maelstrom in slate recently william
salatan argued that quote most americans
are conflicted about abortion they don't
like it but they also don't like the
idea of banning it
end quote this argument is backed up by
poll numbers but the position itself is
not contrary to what celatan suggests a
conflicted one believing abortion
necessary while not liking it is
internally consistent and both nuanced
and moral
i have friends who have had abortions
most people probably do whether they
know it or not
one of my friends escaped an abusive
home became addicted to heroin and got
pregnant very young before boarding the
fetus getting her act together and
becoming a scientist
that part where she got her act together
and became a scientist for less likely
had she been a teenage mother
so it i explore a lot
in this piece
and i really would hope for us to be
able to show my screen
um
i'm wondering if there's any chance of
you showing can you try again zach
okay
um so there's the thing that i that i
linked to in those paragraphs with
regard to
what americans think is some gallup poll
numbers uh which have since i i now have
the numbers through 2021 and some graphs
here
uh which i'd love to show and so maybe
we um maybe we can come back to it uh
don't just show my screen though zach
just tell me when you want to try so
that i can go back to the right place
yes now or yes okay
okay
um
the point and alito actually um writes
this in uh in his the very opening
paragraph of his opinion as well is he
talks about the three groups
he says
you've got a group of americans who
think
that abortion is always wrong no matter
what the circumstances
you have a group of americans who think
that a more abortion should be allowed
under any circumstances
and you have a a third group and the way
he writes it almost seems like an
afterthought maybe a fringe group maybe
a tiny group
who thinks that abortion should be
allowed but with limits
and what the
gallop numbers reveal and what frankly
you think it's showing now
yeah yep great um what these gallop
numbers show uh
great is uh that
the the majority actually it's not quite
the majority at this point of americans
um
about half of americans feel that
abortion should be legal and the wording
here is only under circumst certain
circumstances so as of 2021 the last
year for which data are available under
the gallup polls you have 19 believing
that abortion should be illegal in all
circumstances 32 believing that it
should be legal under any circumstances
and 48 being believing that abortion
should be legal only under certain
circumstances
and um i don't have access or i didn't
find time to figure out what the wording
exactly was
um but i suspect actually that those um
that those two groups of legal under all
circumstances and legal only under
certain circumstances would change a
little bit if the language was something
like um
something like
uh
under any circumstances
but not in the third trimester unless
the life of the mother or the child are
at risk right uh and frankly that right
there which i hadn't thought of before
but which is a framing that many many
many people have used is frankly where
and you know should it be the end of the
third trimester should it be in the
first trimester should it be halfway
through the second trimester there's a
lot of gray area there a lot of wiggle
room there but um you know
no elective abortions in the third
trimester is
put you know me having that as my
strongly held belief that i have had
forever
um
even when i had a much less nuanced
approach to this issue in other ways
would put me in this legal only under
certain circumstances uh category which
fully half of americans put themselves
in the you know people most people if
you really ask them carefully uh do not
actually think that elective abortion
the day before a woman is due to give
birth is okay
right so
a this is reflective of the same dynamic
that the hidden tribes report found
across almost everything right is that
there is this vast middle ground that
more or less agrees within you know a
standard nuance or two yeah
about most of the issues that supposedly
we can't come to agreement about and
what's happening is that these fringes
are bossing us around
they are causing us to understand these
as unresolvable issues now row itself
contains this nuance yes right so it has
the language around viability right or
is it trying i don't remember it's
trimester's reliability and yeah i think
it was uh viability and then it's
modified but modified by later decision
but
nonetheless the point is
and i think one of the things that we
should do is we should stop
thinking of it in terms of fine until x
because that causes the brain to hang up
that's not really what's going on what's
going on is the earlier you go in
pregnancy
the fewer
moral issues exist there at all and at
the point that you're talking about you
know
uh an unimplanted uh cluster of cells
right there's really only one argument
against it
maybe one and a half and it's a
religious argument which i don't think
is a necessarily bad argument people are
entitled to have their own philosophical
relationship with the universe
and to the extent that they feel like
hey you know what that was going to be a
human being and who gave you the right
to say
it
doesn't get to be one i don't think
people who hold that unusual
position are in a place to tell the rest
of us how to think about it but
nonetheless i don't think that they are
saying something insane i think
that they're
it never goes to zero for me yeah if
they are um there there are people and
it is a small minority
who have strongly held consistent
non-hypocritical positions with regard
to the sanctity of human life and i will
add human there because these these are
not people who believe in the sanctity
of life
um you know such people do exist um
right is it the chains no it's the
there's some
there's some group um in in some
religious group uh that really you know
doesn't tries not to tread on you know
anything at all but of course we're
still eating live things you know things
that we have killed to eat them so it's
just simply impossible um to try to
preserve absolutely all life if you are
yourself alive
um so sanctity of human life believers
who are consistent on abortion and on
the death penalty for instance
um are you know that that is a position
that is
not one that i agree with um but is well
formed and arrived at honestly
and um i would hope
that that such people do not end up
making policy that the rest of us have
to live under um but
but there it is
there is a lot of hypocrisy in a lot of
the positions that people have with
regard to abortion and you know as i
also say
uh in this piece well i mean a couple of
things actually one is that
it is estimated
that a majority of human pregnancies
miscarry before the woman even knows
she's pregnant
and so the fact of first trimester
miscarriages that is when the body
decides or abortions when the individual
decides on behalf of the body
are
are
common and miscarriages are in fact so
common
in part because um
a lot of combinations of gametes of of
egg and sperm just aren't viable there's
there's some there's some problem early
development is a fragile and difficult
process uh early in pregnancy is when
exposure to any kinds of toxins um are
particularly damaging uh to to the fetus
and this is you know this is this is why
morning sickness this is why food
aversions tend to be concentrated early
you know early in pregnancy in that
first trimester there's a whole lot of
insult and injury that can happen to a
fetus wanted or not
uh that you know that the fetus being
wanted or not that can cause it to uh
miscarry to self-abort
and so the earlier the earlier in a
pregnancy uh that
uh that an abortion
happens
the the less
the less moral quandary we should find
ourselves in but your point is it's not
a black and white line right and in fact
i again make this argument too there are
a couple of there are a couple of lines
that we can point to right in pregnancy
there's
and and in the beginning of human life
there is birth
inside or outside the mom's body and
there is conception now have the sperm
and egg met or have they not and those
two lines
are the ones that that people at those
two extremes seem to be fighting over
and
many of us and i think it's actually
most of us are saying actually those two
hard and fast lines their only virtues
are that they are hard and fast and you
can point to them they are non-arbitrary
in one way and only in one way you can
point to and you can say yes inside the
mother's body or outside born or not yes
um egg and sperm have met or they have
not and you know there are some others
implanted in the uterine wall all of
this but those are the two that are
easiest to point to and they neither of
them i posit is the right line to to
draw any kind of border at with regard
to abortion rights and i would point out
also that
a mature discussion and i am not under
the impression that uh
civilization at large is about to have a
mature discussion about this but the
fact is
for people in um
subsistence circumstances ancestors who
uh
did not live in a technological society
but um
were subject to
the whims of nature with respect to how
much resource it was going to deliver
right the question of
you know humanness and
what happens to an individual doesn't
necessarily you know get settled at
birth either in other words infanticide
is something that occurs in
circumstances it's not even just in
humans right we see it in other animals
and the point is
the
[Music]
um
the fluctuations in the environment mean
that the decision the physiological
decision to conceive
right is made in one circumstance and
that circumstance can change right or
you know that's not the only way that
this happens but the point is we live in
a prosperous civilization we are
perfectly well equipped to say you know
what we can solve this dicey issue and
we can say you know we can all agree
that at the point you are born you are
deserving of the protections of a human
being and we can ask whether those
protections extend backwards before you
were born because we can recognize the
absurdity of imagining that there is
something you know magical about the
instant at which you transition right
and even questions of something like
it's a tough word there uh right
even questions of something like uh
viability are
absurd if you scrutinize them from a
biological perspective because the fact
is human beings are so utterly helpless
at birth that the fact that they
transition to outside of the womb and
they start taking in resources through
their mouth rather than their umbilical
cord is itself in a way arbitrary right
selection has made human offspring
utterly dependent on adult care for many
years after they are born so we are the
rhythm we remain the most altricial and
is the the most helpless and dependent
on the adults who love us uh for so long
for the longest period right of of any
of any any organisms that we know of
right so in any case the point is i
actually think that if we were to do
this philosophically rather than with
all of our amygdalas activated and you
know
fighting the next civil war here yeah if
we were to do this properly we would
recognize that the moral and ethical
considerations actually don't even start
at conception right there's a question
about you know well what do we think
about whether or not it's cool to
potentially impregnate somebody that you
wouldn't uh
wouldn't want to have anything to do
with if it made them
pregnant right
having sex with somebody who you have no
intention of partnering with
should you be allowed to do that i think
so is it a good idea i don't think so
but what are we to do you know is there
zero moral content in that question i
don't think so i think that there is a
question that starts even before
conception that conception you know is
as you point out has one virtue as a
starting point for the discussion which
is that it's non-arbitrary right right
and birth has that same virtue it's
non-arbitrary but really the fact is
what you've got is kind of you know an
asymptote towards you know birth where
we reach a place where we all agree no
this isn't your choice and we have you
know a kind of
power law tale of the distribution over
at conception where it's like well
actually there's some question about you
know how we're supposed to be
interacting with each other sexually
anyway
and you know the basic point is
haha
we kind of all agree not necessarily on
how we feel about you know a particular
point in the developmental trajectory
but we all agree
with the exception of these fringes that
push us around yep we all agree on the
idea that there's some question that
gets more and more precipitous the
longer this fetus has been gestating
and
the crazy part is that given that we all
not all given that the largest group of
us agree on that that this is a this is
a function right that gets uh
the moral content becomes uh more
concentrated and important the later in
the process we're talking about we
should be able to navigate this and say
well okay
what do we what do we collectively think
at what point do enough of us agree that
um
that this is a being deserving of
protections um that you know we can rule
it out beyond this point what do we do
with the
fact that we may say oh this you know
fetus has gotten to a point where we
believe it deserves protections but the
mother also deserves protections right
these are questions that can be
navigated yeah i know and i think you
know this is this is an issue that of
course comes up in some of the religious
conversations around it that um
you know a child conceived by rape
it is it is argued is um did did nothing
wrong well the child should not suffer
the
suffer for the sins of of
their father is is how the saying goes i
think unless i butchered that which i
think i didn't um so the child should
not suffer for the sins of their father
um but the woman
who was raped
should not suffer for having been raped
right so this this is actually a kind of
moving you know
moving the punishment on you know moving
more punishment on to someone who has
already been actually victimized and of
course any language about
victim and victimhood and victimization
has become
so
badly destroyed
by the
um insane conversations that are
happening on what i insist on calling
the pseudo left of late
that it is it is hard to do this and
um
and know that
you know i or we will be able to get the
careful attention of people on the right
because the people people on the right
people um on say the other other side of
the abortion issue or just in general
who say you know what no i'm
conservative you know why because
the left until until
on may 2nd 2022
this opinion was leaked so many on the
left were gleefully pretending that men
could turn into women and women could
turn into men and they all know they
can't they all know that's not true like
maybe there's a tiny fringe of people
and i'm sorry for them and you know they
are suffering mental delusions um but
everyone knows that this can't happen
that mammals aren't hermaphrodites never
have been never will be this does not
pretend that intersex people doesn't
exist it doesn't even pretend that true
trans people don't exist on which there
are reasonable arguments right but the
idea that oh well men can get pregnant
nope sorry you know better you know
better you always have and now
this dancing the dancing around that's
happening like oh you know
women's rights but also uh if you feel
like wearing lipstick you're a woman
wrong no women's rights but if you're
convicted of a crime you can declare
yourself a woman and go to a woman's
prison even if the crime is one of
sexual assault against women right so
where you may end up impregnating one of
the inmates if that's the kind of person
you are and guess what the inverse can't
happen why not because claim all you
want you aren't a woman and therefore
you can't get pregnant
so they have they the blue team has
undercut its own uh this is there used
to be our chickens coming home to roost
at some level and i am so
angry at them you know this this is part
of why we insist like you know what our
conclusions about um about much of what
we would like to see in the world and
how to do it and our virtues and our
worldview have not changed and we have
seen things just slide out from under us
and they kept the language like they
kept the words no you like
you guys over there who destroyed our
ability to talk about reality and men
being men and women being women and you
can't go back and forth um
that that paved the way
for
a
a a conservative part of the country to
say
i'm not going to listen to anything you
say now i don't i don't believe you if
you're going to argue um that actually
women's rights are necessary and that we
need to be able to have access to
abortion because it is only in that way
that some number of women are actually
going to be able to end up see being
being all that they can be in the world
it is really hard to take people
seriously when they say that if
yesterday they were saying i feel like a
woman today so therefore i am
so we have a problem in getting to
that
conversation which has to happen yes the
problem is that however we got here
the
the dynamics of the argument are such
that anybody who strays into the middle
is going to find themselves picked off
sometimes by both sides right that this
is a third rail issue we've called it a
buzz saw issue there's no room for
anybody to um
to express nuance can i just say that i
discovered this week what i should have
known before is that the episode in
which we talked about dodging the buzz
saw and we named it dodge and the buzz
saw was one of the episodes that was
redacted by youtube and no longer exists
on youtube so just extraordinary yeah i
don't know what to think about this i
didn't even know that
that it had been removed but anyway we
should come back to that and find out
what happened it's very odd that that
seems to be gone but nonetheless the
point is
a i want to revive a principle which i
don't know when the last time i
discussed it was but
i don't consider myself a centrist
right
i think i have
i call myself a reluctant radical and
what i mean by that is i think only
radical change can save our civilization
and maybe our species and therefore as
terrifying as radical change is i don't
think we have any choice about i don't
want to be a radical i want to get to a
position where i can stand down my
radicalness because i don't think it is
safe you have said that you want to live
in a society where you can be a
conservative i want to live in a society
so good that i get to be a conservative
yes but for the moment i'm a radical i'm
a f i'm a progressive and it doesn't
mean i believe what most other people
who use that label believe in fact i
disagree with them about almost
everything
but nonetheless
the problem is
we need to have a conversation in the
center
right the center is not
cool because that's where the truth is
the center is where we meet to discuss
how we are going to govern ourselves
when we don't agree
and we have to have this conversation
and frankly all sorts of people who you
and i like disagree with us on this
question they have yes what is i think
at least in origin a religious
perspective that says look
you don't have the right to
end what would become a human being at
any point after that process has started
you have the right not to produce such a
person but you don't have the right once
the process is going to override it i
don't agree that that's likely to be
right and like when we can't govern
ourselves that way you know as you point
out a huge majority of people disagree
with that right there's the almost 50
percent in the middle who believe yeah
it's more than 80 who disagree with that
position right so we have to come to
some agreement about
to the extent that there are going to be
limits what are they to the extent that
there are going to be protections what
are they how can we minimize the harm of
both i guess i mean that's
maybe
i never said the numbers together but
maybe that's the most important take
home from that gallup polling is that as
of the last poll on abortion by gallup
in 2021 more than 80 of americans they
imagine if the sample is accurate um
felt that abortion needed to be legal at
least in some circumstances
right
or it should be and so again i want to
point out this asymmetry right there
there are people who hold an absolute
position on this that it is never
abortion is never permissible right
i don't agree with them and i think that
actually we can
analytically point out why even given a
most religious positions that is not the
logical endpoint of of the question
but
nonetheless i respect
i respect the position right i do not
respect the position on the other side
right there is this
ghoulish
anti-natal
um
hostile to babies frankly position on
the other side that i find despicable
and
right that asymmetry i don't believe
that that's my asymmetry in perspective
i believe that that is actually an
asymmetry in
uh in intent on these two sides yeah i
mean i think it's um
there have been many examples uh
but there has been sort of
glee
around the idea of allowing abortion all
the way through the end of the third
trimester which again is to say right up
until the moment of birth
and
you know that's not without precedent in
other cultures other cultures have
infanticide yeah
we don't want to be those cultures we
have no interest in being in in being
those cultures and yes i am saying that
in that regard we are better than that
we are better than that and our cultural
mores are better than that and i'm not
saying that we are universally better
than people who also have infanticide as
part of their culture but in that regard
we are better than that and we are
better than allowing abortion in the
third trimester unless there are
extenuating circumstances specifically
the ones that come to to top of mind are
uh the life of the mother or the baby
are at risk right now we do see on the
other side politically we see
uh
a an indifference in the case of
uh rape for example right yes we have
just seen the governor of oklahoma make
an important announcement in which no
allowance uh is being made
for a rape victim and in this case i
think
it is obvious that this is
a political and b uh what would the term
be misogynistic misogynistic and uh
deeply inhumane yes um and the point
that i would make is
you know you've already heard me say i
don't think that the amount of moral
question with respect to terminating a
pregnancy drops to zero even at
conception i think
it gets low enough that we can say look
there's plenty of room for you to make
your own decisions but
um what we can't do is say
well actually
you know
that zygote has uh it's going to be a
human being so it is a human being and
negate the fact that there's another
human being who's already very much a
human being who has just suffered a a
terrible circumstance and you're about
to inflict a change that you know turns
that into a permanent condition on her
and so the point is you have to do
something with respect to the inherent
rights of this woman who did not choose
to be raped and um you know and frankly
any reasonable god would take that
position too yeah and even
so take um
take that's that out of the discussion
for the moment now we're not talking
about
a pregnancy that's due to rape but now
about a pregnancy that's due to
a consensual act but in which neither
neither willing partner were interested
in producing a baby either they were
stupid or their birth control failed or
something else right
uh the fact is that men and women are
different and again every human being
has ever recognized this and it's just
in the last you know two minutes um in
human history not even so um that some
number of people have been gleefully
pretending that that's not the case
um but that
when such uh a situation happens um it
is one and only one of the two people
who are participating on whom the entire
um
brunt rests right
and
uh that is unfair
and it's real and there's nothing to be
done about the unfairness men and women
are different it's biologically unfair
it is biologically unfair and biology
has handed us some number of things
that um render us
different and in some cases that
difference actually makes us unequal
that's just true
and with regard to the sexes uh which uh
you know there there are there are many
places where we can talk about this i've
talked elsewhere in here as well about
you know differences in interests
greater variability in intelligence in
men um compared to women but you know
same average intelligence you know and
you know a different amount of like
myelination in the brain different sizes
of corpus callosums like so many things
besides the totally obvious things that
every human being has ever noticed so
okay that's true
it takes two to tango it takes two to
make a pregnancy and then we have the
pregnancy is only manifest in the woman
so this is this is
a feminist issue in that it's not just a
woman's issue it's a human issue that uh
pertains to to men as well but it is a
feminist issue in that
we should be figuring out how to
decrease the number of unwanted
pregnancies as much as possible
allow women who find themselves in the
position of having
gotten into an unwanted pregnancy a way
to get out of that as early as possible
with the understanding that the woman
did not get herself into that situation
on her own there was a man involved as
well
so that not just men who are free and
clear once they maybe make a mistake
that results in a pregnancy but women
too
can
move forward with greater wisdom with
greater caution and with still the
capacity to make the difference in the
world that they want to make um
i believe that that's right and i
believe that we
um
we make this argument in a different way
in our book and i think really this is
the point about the middle ground here
which is
you and i are not we will be understood
to be arguing for
some
return to the past and that is exactly
not what we are arguing we are arguing
for a renegotiation and the problem is
we had a very
naive renegotiation or maybe a total
failure to negotiate anything at the
sexual revolution where it just became a
free-for-all that has brought us to this
absurd and
exploitative
uh moment in history in which let's let
women behave like men at the worst right
exactly which doesn't uh make women
happy not let like let's let actually
because you did and you you said this
before like we aren't like let for sure
but let's encourage right like let's
let's really push for you know everyone
to behave like
i don't know i won't say but men at
their worst right right no why why would
we do that why would we encourage
newly bad behavior um like the bad
behavior that one sex is already
engaging and sometimes um why would we
try to spread that around it's not even
encourage we actually make women feel
bad if they're not into the idea of
casual sex even though
the reason i mean the irony here and one
of the reasons that you
have to take a evolutionary biological
perspective not to figuring out what to
do next but to understanding how we
ended up here right the fact is
in fact i saw i saw claire layman say on
twitter yesterday
um that
basically if you
um
she was talking to men and she said
something like if you're the kind of man
who would [ __ ] a woman that you wouldn't
want to marry if she got pregnant and
you oppose abortion you're a hypocrite
now i don't actually disagree with what
i think she's trying to say but the word
hypocrite doesn't belong in there
because the fact is men are wired to try
to impregnate women who will not require
them to invest it's something we should
oppose it's utterly immoral but the
point is that is actually
an evolutionary wiring and women
are wired to prevent men from getting
away with it right and this actually
irony of ironies produces the asymmetry
in men and women that actually
causes all of the intrigue around
romance right this is you know it's a
very ugly way for this dynamic to get
started but the point is actually a lot
of the richness of human existence is
downstream of this right
forcing bad men to reveal their intent
and therefore limiting your choices to
good men who are interested in investing
in you long term is you know that's what
courtship is about
and so in any case
i don't know how we have this discussion
if we have to pretend that's not true
right the asymmetry exists it's handed
to us from a long lineage of ancestors
it is modified radically at the point
that um
that control of birth becomes a
conscious choice
due to technology well there's a
i mean this is obviously a much longer
conversation
but there's a
conflation between
fast easy sex that's in front of me
and sexual pleasure
and the conflation results both in the
confusion that you're talking about
right now that if you
if you yourself say you know what casual
sex not for me you are understood to be
a prude who actually isn't interested in
sexual pleasure
similarly at least one more example of
this although i think there are likely
to be many is um and this is true i
think more for men than for women but if
you are a
man
who says actually i don't watch porn
in fact you are much more likely to be
um a
wonderful partner for some woman who
actually cares much more um and you know
and gets more sexual pleasure yourself
but actually is able to provide more but
you are understand understood by society
to be
out of the loop somehow weird mate like
what's that about right and that is
backwards that is the backwards version
of what should actually be understood
with regard to
um how you know how porn
is twisting uh especially
men's especially young men's
visions of what sex is and what
relationship is and what sexual pleasure
can be
and um similarly casual sex
um but
yes a little different well so we we
belittle women who do not sign up for no
we in society the little women for not
signing up for symmetry with men which
as you point out here is absurd because
we shouldn't expect them to have a
symmetrical view
now men are certainly wired to find the
prospect of um
commitmentless sex very exciting because
it's such an evolutionary bargain right
and the point
i don't i don't know if we've made this
point anywhere exactly but
i would argue
you know we have we have made this
argument in several different places
that uh
men have two reproductive strategies the
no investment one and the high
investment one and the high investment
one is not the same as the female
strategy but it's similar and the level
of investment and the level of
choosiness just over consistently it's
three
well i'm going to lump the okay so one
of them obviously is rape which has
happened far too much
i mean any is too much but the point is
there's been a lot of it and it is a no
investment strategy and i think i think
it's not useful to lump them i think
because for the following reason they're
you know they're
large broadly speaking there are three
male reproductive strategies
there is rape which is
should be universally understood to be
deplorable and and we should try to
minimize that to zero
there is the um you know love them and
leave them
the cad the cad there a lot of these but
you're one of your students also had a
oh uh sew and go sew and go the
so-and-go strategy
which is the strategy that has
historically been only a male strategy
but which now women are being encouraged
to engage in and then there is the um
investment with a partner and in the
children that result strategy which we
don't have a fancy name for and that's
maybe part of why it's not as obviously
sexy um but you know you were lumping
those first two together and i i don't
think that's useful because it will be
harder for those people who are
finding success with selling goes like
hey this is fun like what i'm not a
rapist like what are you doing why would
you literally with that right
it was my error to lump them and one of
the reasons that it's my error is
because what i said is that men are
wired
to find commitment-less sex uh
exciting and and the point is and some
some cretins do it one way and some do
it another way right and i would point
out just flag for later um one of the
insane things that we are allowing to
happen is an awful lot of rape play in
porn and elsewhere and this is
normalizing that which is making it uh
more likely to occur in the world when
in fact what we need to do is take the
potential for rape and rule it out at
the software level right right society
we need to discourage um yeah that's not
actually that's actually not okay right
but nonetheless let's let's take the two
strategies that are short of force yes
of men okay so you've got one strategy
which is so and go no investment and the
other strategy which is high investment
and is
uh
yin-yang symmetrical with the female
strategy
one of these the so-and-go strategy
is antagonistic
okay
the
high investment strategy is
collaborative and so
in my opinion we ought to be
discouraging antagonistic sexual
relations it's bad for society it's bad
for the people who participate in them
do i want to tell you you're not allowed
to do that no you're allowed to do it
but
do
i think it's a good idea
no right it's like you know
um you know if you if you own a
beautiful house should you you know go
at it with a sledgehammer and have a
bonfire in the living room no you
shouldn't you could be allowed to i
guess but um
you know it's it it's not wise yeah
right
um so anyway i don't know i don't know
whether um that distinction will land
for people or not but i think the point
a i think it's liable to be less
intuitive for women because if you're
not a man you may not understand that
this is actually that you know
one of the attractions that men have for
women is not
collaborative or flattering right right
it's predatory
and the fact is yes we can make it low
consequence um so the predatory you know
it's a it's play predation but
basically the idea of
sticking a woman with a pregnancy and
not intending to take care of that
consequence yes it's an evolutionary
bargain and you know
you know so might invading your neighbor
country because they don't have a lot of
weapons right it's not
just because it's a evolutionary winner
doesn't make it defensible that's right
um
so did you have somewhere next you
wanted to go ahead one more thing on my
i think or we're getting to the end here
why don't you let you do what you're
going to do well i i have concern about
it because people will hear it
incorrectly which i know maybe we can
um
we can set the stage properly
as evolutionary biologists we are aware
of the importance that genes play in the
evolutionary story that is inherent
understanding what the genes are up to
is
fundamental to unpacking a question
surrounding human reproduction and
modern tech and all of that you have to
understand what the genes are trying to
do in order to figure out how to
position yourself to
defeat them when they're up to no good
etc right
in no way
am i or are we advocating that we do
what the genes want done in fact we have
very directly said we have an obligation
the genes are amoral
what they want is to get into the future
many of the ways that they get into the
future are
utterly horrifying and must be opposed
for moral reasons some of the ways that
they want to get into the future are
utterly beautiful and should be
amplified
it's a it's an a la carte world we have
to choose the things the genes want that
we should agree with and we have to
choose the things that we are forced to
oppose for moral reasons so
please don't take anything i'm saying
here because i'm pointing out what the
genes are up to
as indicating that
i am in any way suggesting we go along
with it
but there's an argument i never hear
about the question of
abortion reproductive rights etc
we frequently talk about the need which
some people don't recognize for an
exception to any limit on abortion in
the case of rape right you and i believe
firmly that there has to be an exception
i believe it goes beyond that this is
not that in fact the argument for an
exception is effectively
uh
absolute
from a genetic perspective and the
reason for that is that there has been
so much rape in human history that we
all every single living human
carries the genetic potential right many
of us carry it we're just carriers right
we don't transmit it because
decent upbringing and
all make this
a non-issue many of us are also women
effectively incapable of rape
okay
but the point is the genetic potential
for rape exists in us because there's
been so much rape in human history and
one of the great successes of society is
in reducing the amount of it
dramatically by punishing it severely
and pursuing instances of it
we drive the amount of it down which is
great and we should do better
but here's the question
if we do not
carve out an exception for a woman who
has been raped right if we compel a
woman to give birth to a child we say
well why punish the child you know for
the sins of the father well it's not a
question of punishing the child
presumably you should want that abortion
as early as possible there is no child
there's a potential child but there's no
child and there is a woman right she
needs to be protected but more to the
point if you force raped people to give
birth to the children that have been
produced by this act you are
creating a conduit for any genetic
predisposition towards rape
to use this strategy to spread itself
right
we cannot open that door
right we have to keep that door closed
and the way you keep that door closed is
you provide the opportunity for anyone
who finds themselves in that terrible
predicament
to um
to terminate the pregnancy so that
rapists are not rewarded that their
strategy cannot work right rape is a
strategy for putting your genes into the
future by overriding someone else's
consent
right and we cannot allow the genes to
find that mechanism and we cannot allow
rapists to figure out how to exploit it
right it has to be a zero-profit
strategy and that requires that
exception
that's fascinating i hadn't thought
about it in those terms before and i
think um
yeah i wasn't i didn't know where you
were going and i didn't expect that from
you in part because you and i both
unlike what people expect from
evolutionary biologists in general
uh tend to find genetic explanations for
human behavior in many fewer places than
most people in including many
non-evolutionary biologists like really
we are so much more software uh that is
to say culture and consciousness than we
are hardware which is to say genetics
that explains so much of what we are
behaviorally um that you will very
rarely hear either of us make an
argument that there might be a you know
a genetic
basis for behavior x
and in fact you didn't argue that there
is or that it is strongly genetically
heritable what you argue it is
given that there might be
give and given and you know and it's
also true that even if it's not genetic
that there might be something
epigenetically um that is that is
conveyed
um
you know
methylation or something right uh that
uh that there is a
there is an additional reason
to always allow whatever other
restrictions there might be um and you
know i would hope that there would be
you know none up through at least the
end of the first trimester and perhaps
halfway through the second trimester on
abortions um that rape victims are
allowed uh exemptions to any
restrictions on abortion that there are
although you know any again you know i'm
not
i you know there will be gray area
somewhere somewhere later on um
sure we can time right in in the in the
development of the
the
fetus the zygote fetus baby
so you're absolutely right i don't think
that there's like liable to be um
so when we talk about heritable we're
talking about the differences between
individuals and that matters here for
reasons that will be obscured to most
people but the point is you have to have
a difference between individuals in
their propensity to engage in this
strategy at the genetic level in order
for it to be heritable in this sense i'm
not arguing that i think those things
exist i'm arguing that they might and
i'm arguing that if they do they can't
become an advantage or they will be
elaborated so you're right you you saw
exactly why i structured it the way i
did but i would also point out
that given what you and i do believe
which is that um you know
human genes are
uh
spectacularly unique in one important
regard which is that they
create a mind in which all of the
important stuff of humanity takes place
on the software side not the hardware
side that's the strange and amazing
thing about the human genome but even
given that and even given what it says
about where these propensities are
housed the same argument still applies
right a rapist
who whether he consciously understands
what he's up to or not
is
uh
getting off on the idea of
having sex with some fertile person and
her dealing with the consequences and
him walking away
that person
needs to know
that there is no
product of his uh
his
activity that the state is going to
force into being okay so to your credit
i think you do a terrible job
caricaturing the mind of a rapist
uh and but i but i hear the arguments
that will come back like oh you know
rape isn't about sex it's about power
wrong but um oh no one's thinking about
whether she's fertile or not it's like i
don't care what's in the conscious mind
of the rapist and i am quite certain
that almost no rapist ever has had
anything like the kinds of thoughts that
you just imagined were in their minds
not consciously that doesn't mean that
the strategy doesn't exist well let me
take away the two negatives
still the strategy does exist because it
has functioned that way regardless of
what has been conscious in rapists minds
yeah so i'll say it uh yet a third way
which is something excites the rapist
and to the extent that it might be the
prospect that the state is going to
effectively side with them uh
um
no the state has to side with the woman
it's unambiguous and
the degree
let's put it this way the absurdity of
the religious position that would have
to exist and i know it does in some
minds but if you've thought about this
issue
right
who exactly is this god that would cause
one person to rape another and then
condemn the raped person yes to give
birth to the offspring
of the rapist now i'm not arguing god
loves her less
right what the hell what kind of god are
we talking about or you know did your
god create a universe in which things
happen and they put us in circumstances
where we have to make uncomfortable
judgments and this is one of those
things right you know i i feel like
almost all religious people would have
to recognize that if
um
if they came to the table and looked at
the actual
not just the issue that they're focused
on but the other issues that it is in
tension with and in this case there
clearly are other issues indeed
well
i think we've come to the end of it yes
you don't mean the end of civilization i
don't know
hey that could be the next current thing
we'll be back in three days unless
civilization has ended by then
so we really will we'll be back in three
short days there my god is it loud here
today uh well we're getting we're we're
leaving the live stream just in time
because someone nearby has decided to
break out their their gardening tools no
that's bees it is not bees
very angry
this is far beyond africanized these are
antarcticanized bees
actually those
snow beans yeah yeah they are they're
badasses i mean they wear perkas but
yeah
yeah it's not the waggle dance the
wattle dance yeah oh maddie knows it's
over okay oh we can't see her um
all right we won't do a q a today um but
we'll be back in three days on may 7th
on saturday at our usual time and we
will do a q a then
um
in the meantime uh
boy lots of things i could say but let
me just leave it at be good to the gun
no
try again i'm gonna try it again
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you